in welcher funktion und kleinigkeiten
verändern ist es auch schon welt
verändern oder wir verändern gerade
schon die welt unternehmen das will
jetzt was tun wenn ich sie umsetze
klar also solange es in meinem kopf
bleibt wird sicher schwierig also unsere
welt basiert auf sehr vielen systemen
und konzepten die irgendjemand sich mal
ausgedacht hat die wir dann auch
irgendwie so ausführen ich glaube das
was die philosophie einem näher bringen
kann ist diese konzepte irgendwie zu
begreifen und zu verstehen worauf das
fuß und auf was für annahmen das ganze
fuß und das was die philosophie zeigen
kann ist ob diese annahmen auch richtig
sind oder nicht oder ob vielleicht
irgendwelche anderen sachen daraus
folgen so gesehen könnte man mit
philosophie eigentlich sämtliche
konzepte auch überarbeiten und auf
stichhaltigkeit prüfen und wenden sich
jetzt zum beispiel ein wirtschaftssystem
als ungeeignet herausstellt was man
logisch gesehen nachprüfen könnte gibt
es einen definitiv die möglichkeit etwas
zu verändern
ja weil sich die betrachtungsweise das
eigene kräftigen oder stärken
beziehungsweise verändern und man somit
einem dass auch andere haben kann und
deswegen denke ich wenn man zum beispiel
menschen philosophisch erzieht und sie
zum selbstständigen denken erzählt dass
man unglaublich viel bewegen kann nur
dann wenn alle die philosophie machen es
auch ernst nehmen
also man kann dass jede person dazu
zwingen philosophie zu machen weil meine
meinung ist ja dann verändert die welt
ich glaube das bringt nichts aber wenn
jeder sich dazu entschließen würde zu
sagen hey ich beschäftige mich
philosophie ich glaube das würde die
welt sogar sehr positiv verändern
und deswegen glaube ich dass es
unglaublich wichtig sogar ist das ins
auge zu fassen dass man mit der
philosophie sozusagen nicht nur dem
eigenen fach freund und schöne
philosophie betreibt und schön lange
bücher schreibt sondern dass man sie
halt auch so ein bisschen lernt
anzuwenden
der fakt dass philosophie ist nicht nur
jemand der irgendwie auf einem berg war
nach einem langen gewand und sich
gedanken über höhen macht und wie wir
aus den höhen drauf haben sondern das
sind einfach leute die sich engagieren
allein dass wir jetzt in einem
wohlfahrtsstaat leben in einem
sozialstaat ist eine philosophische
frage die dem ganzen zu grunde legt wie
viele soziale umverteilung sicherheit
gegenüber freiheit als überwachung
gegenüber der persönlichen freiheit des
individuums im staatssystem
wie sollten wir mit diktatorischen
staaten umgehen die unsere werte nicht
vertreten wie sieht es aus mit
entwicklungshilfe sollten die reicheren
ländern die in den ärmeren ländern
helfen aber die ganze abtreibungsdebatte
der freie wille das komplette
rechtssystem all das dem liegen ja
philosophische fragen zugrunde auch wenn
man sich nicht immer sieht und auch wenn
die debatten darüber in der politik
teilweise nicht philosophisch wirken die
einfach nach dem richtigen maßstäbe
hinweisen sich vielleicht wirklich
länger eincremen semester mit wirklich
wichtigen fragen beschäftigt haben
ansätze geben dass sich die politiker
die sich mit dem mit den problemen der
menschen beschaffen sind die philosophie
die dann auch die frage stellen ob dies
letztendlich ankommt und versuchen
antworten zu finden
also ich hoffe zumindest dass
philosophie die welt verändern sollte
weil es die einzige wissenschaft ist die
sich mit diesen grundlegenden problemen
wissenschaftlich fundiert und rational
logisch versucht auseinanderzusetzen und
wirklich lösungen für die grundlagen der
science der existenz zu finden und ich
hoffe mal dass das eher philosophen
machen wie trump und das ist das was im
studium so für mich einfach mitnehmen
dass man einfach was machen muss dass
man dass man nicht nur viel redet dafür
gibt's ja politiker aber das machen
sollten wir selber übernehmen
und da sind wir glaube ich alle ein
bisschen zu passiv also ich kann von mir
reden dass ich bin zu passiv
da geht noch mehr